all the Shahs men is stephen kinzer look
back at the 1953 coup in Iran fifty
years later he reconsiders the roles of
Winston Churchill President Roosevelt
and the CIA it's history on book TV just
under an hour and a half what tonight we
have the tremendous honor of hearing one
of the most veteran world reporters even
if he's a little silly it's real he has
an incredible incredible record and I'd
like to share some of him Stephen Kinzer
is background with you he joined the New
York Times in January 83 after serving
several years as a Latin American
correspondent for the Boston Globe from
1983 to 89 Stephen was the first times
bureau chief in Managua Nicaragua in
their post he covered war and social
upheaval in Central America he next
spent six years in Germany as chief of
the New York Times bureaus in Bonn and
Berlin he covered German unification and
events in other parts of Europe
including wars in the former Yugoslavia
in 1996 the New York Times opened a new
Bureau in Istanbul in order to provide
readers with insight into Turkey a
country which as you well know has
become increasingly important in world
affairs
The Times named Stephen Kinzer as the
first Istanbul bureau chief prior to
moving to Oak Park um Stephen spent four
years as the bureau chief in this symbol
for the New York Times from his
experience there he wrote crescent and
star Turkey between two worlds in their
book he took a personal and up-close
look at Turkey and I we have it in the
library and would highly recommend its
reading to you for his outstanding work
in Latin America Columbia University
awarded Stephen the Mario Morris Cabot
Prize in 1989
the American Turkish council gave him
its media award in 1998 citing him for
reporting that quote offers a portrait
of Turkey that is broadly defined
balanced comprehensive and accurate a
few years ago Stephen was named a
national correspondent of the New York
Times
based right here in Chicago to our
delight he settled in our own very own
Oak Park he not only lives here but he
uses the services of the Oak Park public
library and in writing his newest book
all the shots men an American coup and
the roots of Middle East terror he even
mentions us in the credits oh my
goodness the librarians were thrilled
beyond belief what you hear tonight may
not make you proud of the plan that our
own President Eisenhower and Britain's
Churchill hatched some fifty years ago
this year but you will walk away tonight
with a better understanding of how and
when the fundamental Islamic Revolution
began and what impact those long ago
actions had on our world today I am very
very pleased to present to you Stephen
Kinzer
thank you wow it's great to be here at
Oak Park not just being here in the
library we're actually did do a good
deal of the research for this book but
also being in the hometown of Ernest
Hemingway for a writer cannot fail to
stir some emotions I actually live only
about two blocks from the home in which
Ernest Hemingway lived while he was in
high school and where he did his first
writing I'm hoping that some of the
Karma will blow over towards my part of
the block the readers will have to be
the judge whether any of that succeeded
I doubt that Hemingway ever found a
story really that was as exciting as the
one that I uncovered and tried to put
together while while writing this book
it was just fifty years ago in August of
1953 that the CIA overthrew a government
for the first time that was the
democratically elected government of
Mohammad Mossadegh the prime minister of
Iran now that episode was hardly noticed
in the world press and certainly the
involvement of the United States the
truth of what really happened was
completely unknown at that time at the
time this coup was launched it seemed
like a success for the United States we
had gotten rid of someone we didn't like
and we'd put in someone we did like
indeed for 25 years the period that the
Shah was in power we could still from
the perspective of the US government
consider this operation to have been a
success it's only now looking back on it
from the perspective of 50 years of
history that we can begin to understand
what a fundamental turning point this
1953 coup was this was an episode that
really shaped the whole second half of
the 20th century and had a great
influence on the violent currents that
are racing through the world today it
would not have been possible to realize
this even a few years ago it's only now
that we're able to understand the
meaning of this episode and for
that reason it teaches us a real object
lesson in the long-term consequences of
foreign intervention this isn't just a
story about foreign policy though this
is a wild spy story in which a real-life
James Bond set out almost
single-handedly to overthrow the
government of a foreign country the cast
of characters is truly amazing and one
of the things that I had the most fun
doing and writing this book was piecing
together all the different accounts and
the different interviews and the
different mentions and various books and
articles that had been made of this
episode and try to reconstruct almost on
an hour-by-hour basis what happened
during those days and nights in August
of 1953 I had always asked myself how
one actually does go about overthrowing
a government if you have the assignment
to go into a foreign country and
overthrow the government what do you do
what are you doing the first day and
what are you doing the second day now I
know
in fact I'm available for consulting
let me talk first about why this coup
took place then I want to talk a little
bit about how it happened and finally
look back on it from the perspective of
today along the way I want to try to
introduce you to some of these
larger-than-life characters who populate
this fascinating drama in the years
after World War Two in the late 40s and
early 50s the currents of nationalism
and anti-colonialism were sweeping
through Africa and Asia and Latin
America now in Iran nationalism had one
meaning it meant the desire of Iranians
to retake control over their own oil
resources Iran sits on one of the
greatest seas of petroleum in the world
it was very early in the 20th century
that a small group of visionary British
politicians led by the young Winston
Churchill who was at that time First
Lord of the Admiralty realized that oil
was going to be the key to domination in
the 20th century Winston Churchill saw
World War One on the horizon
he knew that he was going to have to
transform his ships from Coal Fired to
oil fire he knew that the country that
controlled oil would have the decisive
advantage in the coming war and that it
would also have the ability to dominate
the world after the war but Britain does
not produce any oil nor did Britain have
any colonies that produced oil
this led Churchill and a group of other
British officials to concentrate great
attention on this problem it was in Iran
that they managed to seize control of a
huge newly discovered oil resource the
British did this by the simple expedient
of bribing the three Iranian negotiators
at the table and they signed a fan
tactically lucrative agreement which
gave them a hundred percent monopoly on
all of the production extraction
refining and sale of Iranian oil in
exchange for this they were to pay Iran
sixteen percent of the profits these
profits were calculated after the
company had paid a huge tax to the
British government and since the company
was owned principally by the British
government this was essentially paying
taxes to the company itself so even when
the Iranians asked to see the books as
to how the 16 percent of what was
remaining that was calculated they were
not allowed to do that
so naturally during the period of the
late 40s and early 50s as Iranians
became more and more aware of the
injustice of this arrangement seeing the
British at the peak of world power while
Iranians lived in some of the worst
conditions anywhere in the world their
resentment began to grow Winston
Churchill knew exactly what he was
getting when he signed this very unequal
agreement he called Iranian oil a prize
from fairyland beyond our wildest dreams
and was that oil that maintained Britain
at a high standard of living all during
the teens and 20s and 30s and 40s
Iranians began to chafe very bitterly at
this arrangement and it was this
bitterness that propelled to power the
remarkable figure of Mohammad Mossadegh
Mohammad Mossadegh shook the world at
the middle of the 20th century in 1951
Time magazine chose him as it's men of
the year they chose him over Winston
Churchill Harry Truman Douglas MacArthur
and Dwight Eisenhower and they were
right because during 1951 Mossadegh had
a greater influence on the world than
any of those other men he rose to power
at a time when he was already advanced
in age he was a highly
sophisticated intellectual he had been
educated in Europe he was the first
Iranian to win a Doctor of Laws at a
European University he came from a royal
family he was known as highly incorrect
adass aller II from the government his
political platform had really only two
planks one was democracy which meant in
Iran that the Shah should rule as a
figurehead national symbol like the
Queen of England while political power
would be exercised by the elected
parliament and Prime Minister the second
plank was nationalism and that meant
nationalizing the anglo-iranian oil
company which had for years been making
fabulous profits by sucking out Iran's
most valuable resource on the day that
Mossadegh was elected by Parliament to
be Prime Minister before accepting the
honor he made a condition that the
Parliament should vote for the bill that
he had prepared nationalizing the
British oil company the Parliament did
so unanimously most of that rode into
power on a huge wave of popularity it
was based principally on the consensus
that he would be the one who would carry
out this transcendent act of
nationalizing the British oil company
now besides being a visionary
nationalist Mossadegh was also a highly
unusual personality he was extremely
emotional he would break down into tears
literally on the floor of the Parliament
while giving speeches about the
suffering of Iranians sometimes he would
even faint dead away from the strain
although on occasion he was known to
wink at the doctor from the floor he had
a great sense of political theater and
although he had many physical ailments
all during the period I was writing this
book I was never really able to tell
where the physical ailments ended and
where the psychosomatic ones began he
spent a lot of time in bed and he used
to receive diplomats in his pajamas now
these aspects of his personality were
used in the West
to ridicule Mossadegh and make him seem
like a nun serious person but actually
in Iran where centuries of Shiite
religious practice have sensitized
people to public displays of emotion
that are far beyond anything with which
we're accustomed in the West these
aspects of his personality only seem to
endear him even more to Iran ian's he
seemed to suffer with them even as he
was chastising them most addict offered
the British the chance to carry out the
nationalization of the oil company
according to British law if you can
remember in the late 40s and early 50s
the British were nationalizing many of
their own industries at home they were
nationalizing the coal industry and the
steel industry in the railway industry
and they had a very elaborate system
developed for deciding who had to
compensate who in the case of these
nationalizations so most of that offered
to them let's just put it in front of
one of your tribunals and we'll decide
who owes who money now the management of
the oil company was famously obstinate
for years the Friends of the British in
Iran and the friends of the
anglo-iranian oil company in Iran had
been urging the oil company to
compromise to avert this crisis the
American consortium known as Aramco the
Arabian American oil company reached a
deal right around this period with Saudi
Arabia and they gave Saudi Arabia a
50/50 split
this was an agreement that had the air
of fairness that a common person could
understand and many of the progra Iran
urged anglo-iranian to make this
concession the chairman of the company
flatly refused and simply said when they
need more money they will come crawling
to us on their bellies now how did the
British react to the unanimous vote of
the Iranian parliament carrying out the
nationalization of their oil company
this oil company bear in mind was the
largest British commercial enterprise in
the whole world
its principal asset the refinery at
Abaddonn on the Persian Gulf was the
largest oil refinery in the world this
was not some outpost of the British
Empire this was an operation that was
central to British political social and
military power the first we British
reaction was disbelief they thought
Mossadegh was just trying to blackmail
them for a few extra million that turned
out not to be true it became quickly
clear when it became clear to the
British that Mossadegh was deadly
serious
they decided as they had been
conditioned to do over centuries of
colonialism they would simply invade
Iran and take back the oil fields I
actually discovered two invasion plans
they had one plan to take over all of
Iran and a more limited one just to take
over the oil fields and the refinery at
Abaddonn but when Harry Truman heard
about this he went nuts he told the
British this was absolutely out of the
question and the Americans could never
tolerate Britain landing troops in Iran
then the British decided they would
bring the matter to the Security Council
the Americans warned them not to do this
the Americans told them you know if your
case comes forward and the Iranian case
comes forward you're not gonna look very
good but the British so caught up in
their colonial mentality dismissed this
objection they believed that their case
was prim of fasi that they had been
robbed of an oil company and everyone
would understand this well back in
Tehran Mossadegh loved the idea of the
whole thing being taken to the UN he
liked it so much that he decided he
personally would fly to New York and
present the Iranian case when he got to
New York he caused a media sensation he
was a sort of an eccentric figure
bald-headed with enormous arms a very
big nose one of his American translators
said that he makes Jimmy Durante look
like an amputee
he gave a lot of speeches on American TV
comparing the nationalization of the oil
company to the American Revolution he
seemed very much like your very
endearing if mildly eccentric uncle and
Americans really took to him on TV he
made a huge impression at the Security
Council bear in mind that this was more
or less the first time that the voice of
a poor country had ever been raised in
such an August setting challenging the
governing rule of law in the world he
made such an impression that the
Security Council refused to accept the
British resolution it was the first
defeat for a major British resolution in
history of the UN after his triumph at
the UN Mossadegh was invited by
President Truman to come to new come to
Washington to negotiate and consider the
possibility of compromise a compromise
which was never on alas reached the
scene of Mossadegh arriving at the train
station in Washington is a wonderful
example of the way most of that carried
himself most of that often seemed to be
a death's door completely unable to move
or even speak so it was as he was
carried off the train at Union Station
he was leaning heavily on a cane and his
son who was also his doctor was
essentially carrying him on his left
side
if gingerly was brought down the three
steps onto the platform and was able
just to raise his head a bit as he
looked down the platform he saw that to
everyone's surprise an official
delegation had come to meet him and who
was at the head of the delegation none
other than the Secretary of State Dean
Acheson well he had never met Acheson
but had admired him from afar he was so
thrilled to see him that he lept up
pushed his son aside threw his cane onto
the railroad track and according to
Addison skipped merrily down the
platform
embraced me during the stay in
Washington no compromise was able to be
reached the British after their defeat
at the United Nations had resolved that
the last resort was to stage a coup and
overthrow Mossadegh they ordered their
agents in Iran to begin to arrange such
a coup and the agents began to make the
appropriate contacts Mossadegh however
caught wind of this he heard of what was
going on and he did the only thing he
could have done to protect himself he
closed the British Embassy and he sent
all the British diplomats home among
them of course there were all the secret
agents who were planning the coup now
the British had nothing they could not
invade they had no diplomatic tools left
even the World Court had thrown out
their case and they had no agents on the
ground to stage a coup they had lost
their oil company the only thing left to
them was to appeal to the Americans and
Prime Minister Churchill then 77 years
old and starting to fade but still a
real product of the Imperial tradition
longtime lover of clandestine operations
appealed directly to President Truman
Truman turned him down
Truman resisted all of Churchill's
pressures he essentially told him the
CIA has never overthrown a government
before we don't want to get into this
business we don't understand that
country we are not going violently to
intervene in its political development
without understanding it Truman was
worried about the CIA and what it might
become in one of his diary entries he
even used the phrase American Gestapo to
describe what he feared the CIA could
develop into if it were left unchecked
so now the British were finished they
had lost their oil company they had no
tools to get it back and the Americans
wouldn't help them the story might have
ended there had it not been for the
American election of November 1952 in
that election Dwight Eisenhower came was
elected and brought with him a team that
had
during the campaign denounced the
incumbent Truman administration for not
being tough enough on communism and
other threats to American security
abroad
well news of the American election
electrified the British Foreign Office
and the British Secret Service they were
so excited that they could not even wait
for eisenhower to be inaugurated before
making their appeal again two weeks
after the election the British sent one
of their top agents actually a guy who
had been the chief of the British
intelligence station in Tehran before
most of that closed it to Washington his
job was present the plan for the coup to
the new group the incoming Eisenhower
administration and see if you can
persuade them to embrace the project
that the Truman administration had
rejected now the agent who came to make
this appeal later wrote a memoir that I
quote in my book and in this memoir he
mentions this mission and this is what
he writes as I paraphrase it I knew that
our traditional argument would not move
the Americans our traditional argument
was Mossadegh took away our oil company
please overthrow him so we can have our
oil company back this was not an
argument that would move Americans so he
wrote I knew I needed a different
argument and I knew what argument to use
I would say that Mossadegh was opening
Iran up to the possibility of a
communist takeover sure enough that's
the argument that this agent used the
Dulles brothers Secretary of State
designate John Foster Dulles and his
brother Allen the incoming CIA director
jumped at that argument before even
allowing that British agent to go home
more than two months before the
inauguration they had given him an
informal sign that the United States
would now change its policy sure enough
over the next few months President
Eisenhower and all the other members of
the administration
who had a voice in these matters agreed
to carry out this coup jointly with the
British in planning but alone on the
ground in Iran now as I said earlier in
my book I've reconstructed in great
detail everything that happened in Iran
during those weeks of August 1953 I
don't want to go through all those
details now but let me just give you a
general idea of the way the coup was
carried out the CIA chose one of its
most intrepid agents Kermit Roosevelt
actually the grandson of President
Theodore Roosevelt to sneak into Iran in
late July 1953 and begin organizing the
coup now what did he do
first of all he began bribing newspaper
editors and columnist sand reporters to
write all sorts of defamatory lies about
Mossadegh in the newspaper secondly he
began bribing members of parliament and
leaders of political parties that were
part of most index coalition so they
would quit the coalition or they would
begin to denounce Mossadegh he began
bribing mullahs so that at Friday
prayers in the mosques people would hear
denunciations of Mossadegh as being anti
religious or against the Islamic faith
he also through the military attache at
the US Embassy in Tehran began bribing
mid-ranking military officers so they
would be ready with their units to join
the coup when the moment came one of the
most brilliant ideas that he had was to
sow upheaval on the streets of Tehran he
got into the mobs our US business he was
able to recruit several street gang
leaders including the most famous and
flamboyant one in Tehran Chabon the
brainless who ran a protection racket in
the vegetable market and had a lot of
tough guys around him and we're always
looking to earn a few extra bucks or a
few extra reals as it was at that time
this is the assignment that he gave to
shabaan he said I
I want you to get several hundred men
and I want them to rampage through the
streets of Tehran I want them to beat up
anyone they see I want them to smash
shop windows fire their guns into
mosques and shout we love loss attack
and communism
long live People's Republic of Iran well
this would naturally have the effect of
turning any decent citizen against
Mossadegh then in the further
inspiration Roosevelt hired another mob
to attack this mob thereby giving the
impression that the streets of Tehran
were in chaos and Mussa Dec can
completely lost control of a situation
during this time Kermit Roosevelt was
sneaking into the Royal Palace at
midnight concealed under a blanket in
the backseat of a car to meet quietly
with the Shah and secure his
participation in the coup the Shah who
was at that time a very meek and
cowardly and indecisive figure was
terrified of getting involved in
anything that might endanger him given
the power of the US and Britain he
really had no choice in the end but
Kermit Roosevelt had to use a lot of
means to twist his arm he brought
several people in to apply pressure on
the shop one of them was none other than
general H Norman Schwarzkopf the father
of the Gulf War general general
Schwarzkopf had been a very flamboyant
military figure in Iran during the 1940s
when the Shah was a young man and still
had great influence over him their
meeting was amazing the State Department
had given Schwarzkopf a cover mission of
visiting American installations in the
region so that his visit to Iran
wouldn't arouse suspicion although
Pravda immediately figured out what was
up and printed a story denouncing it he
went in to meet with the Shah in the
royal palace
but the shouts so terrified of
microphones that he wouldn't say a word
short scoff and he just gestured
he then pulled a table away from the
wall himself in the Grand Ballroom of
the sada bod Palace he pulled it out
into the middle of the room presumably
furthest possible away from microphones
he climbed up on the chair he gestured
to general Schwarzkopf who then came up
and sat with him and they conducted
their conversation by whispering to each
other on that table through these in a
series of other pressures the Shah was
finally brought on board and his job was
to sign a decree dismissing Mossadegh
from office this was a highly dubious
legality since in democratic Iran only
the Parliament had the right to hire and
fire prime ministers nonetheless the are
the order to the officer who was to
deliver this decree was when Mossadegh
resists as he surely will you arrest him
and then we proclaim our own guy as
Prime Minister the CIA had already
chosen a cashiered Iranian officer as
the designated savior of Iran now what
happened on the night of August 15 1953
the officer who had been chosen to
deliver this decree came to Mossadegh
store and out of the shadows come other
soldiers and they grabbed him it turned
out that the coup had been betrayed the
security services have found out about
it and the officer who was supposed to
arrest Mossadegh was himself arrested so
now the coup had failed the Shah had
only signed this decree on condition
that he could leave to run immediately
he wanted to be near an airport he was a
pilot himself sure enough at 6:00 a.m.
the next morning when he heard that
Mossadegh was still in power he
literally ran across the tarmac into his
little private plane with just a little
Veliz jumped in his plane flew to
Baghdad and later on to Rome where he
told people he'd be looking for work
since he obviously wasn't gonna be back
able to go back to Iran any time soon
well now back in Tehran Mossadegh and
the people around him assumed that the
Shah had been behind this
after all he was the one that had signed
the decree now the Shah was gone so as
far as they knew the danger was over
Mossadegh never had any idea that there
even existed such a person as Kermit
Roosevelt working inside the US Embassy
and paying so many thousands of dollars
and working so intensively to overthrow
him I honestly believe that if most of
that could come back to life and read my
book he'd be shocked he had no idea till
his dying day in 1967 of how involved
the plot was that that resulted in his
overthrow after the first coup failed on
August 15th the CIA in Washington sent
an urgent cable to Kermit Roosevelt
telling him you better get out of there
in a big hurry before they find out who
you are and kill you but Roosevelt
decided I could still do this I'm gonna
stick around I was here to overthrow
this guy and I still have some tools I
want to try again bear in mind this was
a time when CIA agents operated mainly
by their wits they were not in
moment-to-moment communication with
Langley or anywhere else and Kermit
Roosevelt now having to ditch the plan
that had taken British and American
spymasters weeks to draw up came up with
another plan of his own after four more
days of rioting and denunciations of
Mussa deck from various quarters he
struck again on August 19th 1953
28th of more daaad by the Iranian
calendar a fateful day that every
Iranian knows by heart the streets of
Iran were full of rioters and protesters
many of them paid by Roosevelt directly
or indirectly but many I think joining
in without realizing what was going on
there were gun battles as military units
whose leaders had been bribed joined the
fight government buildings were attacked
the climactic battle happened at night
in front of most decks house a hundred
people were killed in
battle alone by midnight most of decks
house was in flames he had fled and the
coup had succeeded a couple of days
later just before leaving Iran Kermit
Roosevelt stopped in to meet the Shah
for one last time this time he was able
to come sitting up in the back seat of
the car in a suit instead of hiding
under a blanket and the Shah toasted him
and said this the Shah having come back
to from Rome where he was sitting in a
restaurant when he learned of the
success of a second coup
I owe my throne to God my people my army
and you which was exactly right although
I think he might have reversed the order
now Kermit Roosevelt came back to
Washington to great acclaim
he gave a briefing at the White House
President Eisenhower later denied in his
memoir that this briefing ever took
place but in actual fact he pinned a
medal on Roosevelt's chest and Roosevelt
later wrote about this session in the
White House he said one member of my
audience
Secretary of State John Foster Dulles
had a wide grin on his face and was
purring like a giant cat my instinct
told me he was planning sure enough a
few weeks later Kermit Roosevelt was
called into his boss's office and told
you did such a great job overthrowing
Mossadegh in Iran we've decided we don't
like that guy down in Guatemala couldn't
you go down there and do it again well
Roosevelt too murdered but another group
was found and less than a year after the
elected government of Iran was
overthrown the elected government of
Guatemala was overthrown with also
heinous consequences leading to hundreds
of thousands of deaths in a savage civil
war that lasted over
thirty years this set the United States
out in the direction of covert action
and regime change it's hard to imagine
today but it was not inevitable that the
CIA be can't become an agency that was
involved in overthrowing governments and
destabilizing countries in fact it
became so only after the established
policy of the u.s. government set by
President Truman was reversed by the
Eisenhower administration so much of
history stemmed from those few weeks in
Tehran let me talk a little bit about
what I mean
as I said earlier that coup could have
been considered a success from the
American perspective for the whole next
25 years that was the period when the
Shah was in power and served as a
faithful ally of the United States but
let's look at it from the perspective of
today the Shahs repressive regime create
shut off all political alternatives for
anybody who was against the dictatorship
the only place they had a principled
opposition and that was rooted in the
Iranian masses was the fundamentalist
branch of Islam fundamentalism began to
attract many people who were
disillusioned with the impossibility of
change any other way in Iran the Shahs
repressive regime led to the explosion
of the late 1970s that we call the
Islamic Revolution that revolution
brought to power a group of fanatically
anti-american clerics who proceeded to
launch a campaign of terror against
American and other Western targets that
regime also inspired fundamentalists in
many other countries including next-door
Afghanistan where the Taliban came to
power and gave sanctuary to Osama bin
Laden and al Qaeda this is why I think
you can say that it's not far-fetched to
draw a line from the 1953 coup in Iran
through the Shahs dictatorship and the
Islamic Revolution to al-qaeda and the
fireballs that engulfed the World Trade
Center in New York the world has paid a
terrible price for the lack of democracy
in the Middle East why is there such a
lack of democracy there when the United
State there are many reasons of course
as I was studying history in college I
was always warned not to draw a direct
cause-and-effect relationships in
history I hope my teacher is not in the
room we sent a message in 1953 that
resounded throughout the Middle East the
message was the United States which is
the rising power to replace the fading
British in this region does not want to
see the emergence of democratic
governments we want strong man rule and
that's what we got a whole generation of
rising leaders in the Middle East
understood that if they wanted to build
regimes that were gonna be supported by
the United States they could not go in
the Democratic direction they needed to
go in the direction of Iran strongman
rule that would guarantee support for
the u.s. in Cold War conflict and also
guarantee access for American companies
to the oil that is the Middle East most
important product so from that one
episode a deep-seated anti Americanism
grew in Iran that spread throughout the
Middle East I want to talk a little also
about the comparisons between this
operation and the operation recently in
Iraq now I do believe that every regime
change in covert action operation that
we have launched in 50 years has some
similarity to the one in Iran this is
where it all began there are a couple of
obvious differences between the Iran
operation of 53 and the recent Iraq
operation one obviously is that one was
a covert operation the other was a
military invasion and in it
rakh the victim was a monstrous tyrant
whereas in Iran the victim was an
elected Democratic leader but there are
many similarities
let me tick off a couple of them first
of all one of the main reasons that both
of these operations were launched was
because the United States felt the need
to strike back against a global enemy
communism in the early 50s and terrorism
in the modern age in both cases we were
not able to get to our real enemy in the
50s we could not invade Moscow or drop
bombs on Beijing so we found a country
that would do we were not able recently
to capture those responsible for the
attack on our soil so we turned our
sights elsewhere and launched an
invasion or operation in another country
that we also had problems with another
reason that I think is behind both of
these operations is a very fundamental
strategic one the United States has
always wanted a country in the Middle
East to be its strategic platform from
which it can extend influence Iran was
that platform for 25 years that's long
gone and with Saudi Arabia looking shaky
air every day I think it's clear that
people in Washington now want Iraq to
play that role another similarity is
certainly oil the access of Western oil
companies on terms they consider
reasonable to Middle Eastern oil is a
fundamental aspect of US policy toward
the Middle East of course it's naive to
believe that big powers ever intervene
in the Middle East without oil being a
factor another comparison between these
two operations was the exaggeration of
intelligence Eisenhower was fed reports
about the imminence of communist
takeover in Iran I quote in my book a
scholar who went out and actually found
the CIA agent and two diplomats who were
posted at the US Embassy in Tehran in
1953 with the job of monitoring
Communist Party and leftist movements
and they told him
we completely exaggerated the strength
of these movements because we knew
that's what the people in the White
House wanted to hear the comparison to
the weapons of mass destruction argument
before the Iraq operation is obvious but
I'd say the the greatest and saddest
perhaps a most awful similarity between
these two operations is that we were so
determined to achieve a short-term goal
and we never stopped to think about what
the long-term consequences of our
intervention might be now as I was
writing my book I was very conscious
that although this story for Americans
is a somewhat intellectual exercise a
story about foreign policy and us Middle
East relations and the direction of
American policy in the world for
Iranians it's something different I've
been speaking before a number of Iranian
American groups lately and I can see
that for Iranians this episode is not
intellectual at all this is something
very visceral and very emotional and
very painful I had an email from an
Iranian American woman recently who
wrote to me I was in tears when I
finished your book because it made me
think of everything we lost and
everything we could have had when you
try to imagine what it would have meant
to have a democratic country in the
heart of the Middle East all these 50
years I must tell you that I myself
can't even wrap my mind around what such
a Middle East would look like because
it's so completely different from
everything that we know but bearing in
mind that this is an Iranian story as
well as an American story I wanted to go
back to Iran and do some research for my
book not in libraries and books since
the real information is here this is
where the coup was planned but among
ordinary Iranians I tried to get a
research visa to get
but after many months of trying it was
clear to me that that was not going to
succeed my goal was to get to Tehran and
actually to Mossadegh house on the 49th
anniversary of the coup that was August
19th of 2002 when I realized that my
journalist visa was not going to be
approved through a roundabout way I
don't want to implicate my companions in
crime I managed to get in as a tourist I
knew the Iranians were on to me though
when I arrived at my hotel and they said
Oh your room is ready mr. Kinser it's
room 911 when I protested I was told
that yes out of all the thousand rooms
in this hotel it's the only one
available for you I took that as a
message that some people knew that I was
there and weren't so happy about it the
present religious regime in Iran likes
the idea of Mossadegh having been
overthrown because that fits in with
their Paragon of Iran always being
victimized by outsiders but they don't
like Mossadegh because he was a secular
liberal who detested fundamentalism so
they don't want to promote any projects
that will give him a higher profile but
I wanted to ask ordinary Iranians after
50 years when it's been more or less
forbidden to speak or write openly about
Mossadegh what do you think about him
what do you know about him I asked this
question to a lot of people everyone I
met I got two answers the first answer
everybody gave me was he nationalized
the oil everybody knows that and the
second answer I got from a lot of people
was we were free then you could say what
you wanted not like today I had great
difficulty getting out to most of the
ex-house American tourists in Iran as I
was only a tourist of course have to
travel with a guide and when I told my
guide I wanted to go to Ahmedabad the
village where most of the expenses last
years I was told this was impossible now
the tourism ministry has a list of about
500 places in Iran where
tourists go and this isn't one of them
he said no one has ever asked to go to
Ahmedabad in fact even this guy who had
written a books on Islamic architecture
and Iranian history had never been there
anyway it's a long story but finally I
managed to get permission to go out
there and sure enough on August 19th of
last year the 49th anniversary of the
coup I was at most of the ex house the
only visitor
after the coup Mossadegh was arrested
and tried for treason convicted and at
the Shahs Direction was given a sentence
of three years in solitary confinement
and the rest of his life under house
arrest at his village he lived in this
village which is about an hour's drive
from Tehran for more than a decade
before his death in 1967 I walked around
the grounds to this country estate they
had a long path of maybe a hundred yards
leading down to a two-story brick
edifice certainly the nicest house in
town but nothing unusual by world
standards this was the compound that
most of that never left for the last ten
years of his life he's actually buried
under the floor of the sitting room
where he used to receive the few guests
that he was permitted there's a small
marker over the spot where he is buried
I have to tell you that while I was
researching my book after learning that
Mossadegh had been on the cover of Time
magazine with some difficulty I went out
and actually got a copy of that January
1952 issue of Time magazine I had it
framed and I had it up on the wall in my
office where I write all the time when I
was writing this book it gave me the
feeling that not only was i resurrecting
an unknown episode but also that I was
bringing back to life a fascinating
figure who has been all but lost to
history despite the fact that he had
such a big impact on on the 20th century
being there in that house completed the
experience that I began of coming into
intellectual and perhaps even a some
kind of emotional contact with Mossadegh
I laid my hand on the little memorial
covered by the simple green banner and
recited that simple Arabic line that
invokes the mercy and compassion of God
as is customary in such situations the
room has various pictures of Mossadegh
that have been brought by admirers I
went outside and walked around the
grounds a bit and against the back wall
of the compound I noticed something
interesting I went over to it and it was
a gate it was not a gate that was set
into the wall just leaning against the
wall I was curiously looking at it and I
noticed they had a big dent in the
bottom and suddenly something dawned on
me six months before Mossadegh was
overthrown the British had tried another
abortive coup and during that coup a
jeep carrying none other than our friend
shabam the brain was smashed through
most of decks front gate in an attempt
to get into his house so I realised this
is the gate from Mossadegh house in
Tehran the house was burned down and the
whole neighborhood has completely
changed since then but this gate still
survives what history this gate has seen
how many ambassadors and dignitaries
came through this gate to pay call on
the bid written Mossadegh through this
gate he walked out to meet the Shah
through the state he went out to his
historic trip to the United Nations in
Washington this is where great crowds
chanted the support for his
nationalization and where ultimately the
crowds gathered that defeated him I lay
my hand on that gate and held it there
for a long time at that moment I felt
that I was about as close to Mossadegh
as I was ever gonna get my experience
talking to Iranian
however made me realize that Mossadegh
is very much alive in their hearts in
Iran today it is illegal to call for any
form of government other than Islamic
regime but when you hold up a picture of
Mossadegh that is exactly what you're
doing you don't need one single word or
one single slogan underneath it because
just his photo represents the hope for a
democratic Iran the large majority of
Iranians today detest the regime under
which they live they want to return to
the Democratic path from which they were
so violently forced 50 years ago and
when they do I'm convinced that
Mossadegh will once again be revered
that that house in Ahmedabad that I
visited will not be empty any day of the
year that it will be filled with
schoolchildren coming on field trips
that foreign dignitaries will come to
that house and lay wreaths that
Mossadegh picture will hang in every
public office as he will be recognized
as the man who laid the basis for modern
democracy in Iran and that perhaps when
that happy day comes it will be time for
Americans to realize as Harry Truman put
it in the epigraph I used for my book
there is nothing new in the world except
the history you do not know thank you
kind of go off I was ready
thank you I've had a request to announce
that our friends from c-span would like
to bring the microphone over to the
questioners so if you could just wait a
second for the microphone to arrive I
think everybody would be happy
what role did the elder general
Schwartzkopf play in creating this cast
to the SAVAK that little in the Shaz era
tortured and killed hundreds perhaps
thousands of people areas like the CIA
and the SAVAK and the MU said work
together the question was whether
general Schwarzkopf senior played a role
in the creation of Saavik which became
the very feared secret police under the
Shahs regime actually he did create a
unit that was the forerunner of Saavik
Schwarzkopf was another fascinating
figure in this drama he was a West Point
graduate and he had gone on to become
commander of the New Jersey State Police
and in that capacity he became a
national celebrity with the
investigation of the Lindbergh
kidnapping he parlayed that celebrity
into radio stardom he became the radio
voice of gangbusters very popular crime
show of the 1930s and 40s he re-enlisted
in the army when world war ii broke out
he was sent to iran his job was to
create a Constabulary that would
essentially work for the Shah and he
created the first tough military unit
there he was the scourge of bandits and
separatists but also dissidents and
opponents to the Shah he created a unit
aimed at ferreting out political
opponents and it was on the basis of
that unit that Saavik was built it's
amazing to think about the second
general Schwartzkopf returning you know
I don't think history really does repeat
itself but history delights in patterns
and the idea that general Schwarzkopf
would play such a decisive role in the
Middle East in 1953 and then 40 years
later his son also general Norman
Schwarzkopf would return to the region
also to play a decisive role is it's a
wonderful little joke played on us by
history so what was creative urema said
that not for exactly that purpose but it
was used differently during the show the
establishment of Sirach is the
abbreviation for the the organization of
information and and security of the
country it was it was established ready
mentally during as a day after his
police chief was kidnapped and tortured
to death by the opposition mostly
religious and others which were bribe as
you mentioned the those who murdered the
police chief were in at least in direct
contact with British intelligence the
British wanted to or let's say agents
work working with the British wanted to
destabilize most of the ex government by
assassinating some of his close
ministers the defence minister and the
interior minister and the chief of staff
proved to be too well guarded so through
a trick they managed to get to the
police chief of Tehran and his
assassination did help contribute to the
destabilization any other questions
according to dr. Abraham Ian I was a
witness of the to the coup today day of
the coup I was in Tehran
I witnessed the whole thing it was not
inevitable it was a very very weak to
begin with and that grew gradually it
was quite defeatable this was nothing
when I think back I think it was total
Mossadegh was too naive
he had come from living in Switzerland
he believed that everybody should be
allowed to speak everybody should be
allowed to demonstrate it didn't matter
if you were being paid by British
intelligence you could have your own
newspaper you could print whatever you
wanted anybody should be able to have
demonstrations in the street no matter
how violent he had no idea as I said
earlier that so much of the opposition
to him was artificially fomented and I
think if he had realized that he would
have been able to marshal his forces and
defeat the school he was actually doing
the opposite he called the leaders of
his own coalition the day before the
coup and warned them don't put any
people on the streets we want to calm
the streets down and we don't want
anyone out there and on the night before
the coup when some of his people did go
out he actually sent his own police to
beat them up so he had no idea of what
was about to happen to him one of the
things I realized when writing this book
is how easy it is for a rich and
powerful country to throw a weak poor
country into chaos believes that
Mosaddegh was fooled the night before
the coup by Henderson who was the
American ambassador who came to his
visit and told him that tomorrow the to
the party which was the Communist Party
I'm gonna attempt a coup so he must have
been as the commander in chief of the
army at that point he was the only one
who could allow the tanks to come out of
the barracks out into the streets and
told him that the tanks go and defeat
disco other one and he was fooled and
let the tanks go and that was his
undoing
what do you think as I understand it
happen a little differently this was a
brilliant psychological operation
devised by Kermit Roosevelt he got the
American ambassador to go in and visit
Mossadegh this was two days before the
coup and feign outrage that American
citizens were being attacked and even
receiving obscene phone calls when
children would answer they would be told
terrible things on the phone the
children should never
have to here and this was a great insult
to America and that if this couldn't be
stopped immediately Americans would be
ordered out of Iran
well Mossadegh who was actually a very
courtly gentleman was quite shocked at
the idea that Americans were being
treated discourteously in Iran and he
immediately called his police chief in
the presence of ambassador Henderson and
told him I want you to crack down on all
those people that are demonstrating on
my behalf on the street this worked like
a charm later on
Time magazine described this as the
crucial moment in the coup because as
they put it their Mossadegh disarmed
himself he was completely taken in by
what was actually quite a transparent
and silly ruse yes sir a bit of
historical trivia in August 1953 I was
at a National Security Agency school and
my instructor was a CIA agent and I
believe is on current events and my
topic was Moser Dec so I gave a report I
said go out he's a little kooky but he
seems to be a good enough politician and
my CIA instructor was very angry and
dissatisfied with my report so it took
me 15 years to realize what I had wrong
well you were out of the loop
first-generation Iranian American and my
dad was witness to the coup and I want
to thank you for writing this book to
give me a little more awareness of what
was happening in Iran because I was born
and raised here never had the
opportunity to live there I want to ask
you did you read anything specifically
about university students and how they
got the university students to and
contribute to overthrowing the coup
because it seems to be a trend in
Iranian culture to bring the students
out onto the street and make them be the
voices for the older generations
interesting question actually students
did not play a role in this coup and
that I think is a phenomenon that began
with the 1979 uprising this brings I
think another point during the research
for this book I had a chance to read a
lot of Iranian history and and I have a
chapter that kind of sets the scene it
takes you back all the way from Xerxes
up to 1890 it's about one word per
decade I think of Persian history one
thing I found very odd when we today
think of Iran we think of a government
that's dominated principally by the
emotion of fanaticism when we think of
an visual image of Iran our most vivid
images the crazy students shouting and
screaming but actually fanaticism is not
a characteristic of Iranian or Persian
culture at all in fact the early Persian
Emperor's were masters of what we would
today call multiculturalism many of the
kingdoms that Cyrus conquered he didn't
even conquer militarily he persuaded
them he built alliances if we can use
that phrase how did fanaticism come to
take over the Iranian body politic I
don't know the answer to that but I ask
myself did the fact that the country's
normal democratic development was so
violently interrupted in 1953
and that 25 years of political
development was so brutally stunted
helped contribute to the fanaticism with
which we now associate Iran while I was
researching this book I came across a
fascinating article written by a
middle-aged Iranian University professor
that would mean way older than me I
guess this guy turned out to have been
one of the hostage takers he was one of
the militants who stormed the US Embassy
in 1979 and took our diplomats hostage
and in this article he writes why we did
it well I was fascinated to read that
because I'm not sure I ever really
grasped why they did it myself and what
he wrote which I quote in my book is
absolutely fascinating he wrote there
was only one thing in our mind as we
planned the embassy takeover 1953 what
happened in 1953 the people of Iran
forced the Shah to flee the CIA
operating with agents inside the US
Embassy organized a coup and brought the
Shah back
now we flash-forward it's 1979 once
again the people of Iran have forced the
shot to flee he's been admitted into the
United States
history is about to repeat itself we
were afraid that CIA agents operating
from inside the US embassy building
would organize a coup and bring the Shah
back again we had to prevent 1953 from
happening all over again the reason was
obvious
well it's only obvious if you even
realize that this episode ever happened
and also appreciated how intensely the
memory of it still burned in the hearts
of Iranians I ask myself whether the
American policymakers who brought the
Shah into the United States were even
fully aware of what had happened in 1953
and what would immediately come to the
minds of any politicized Iranian I don't
know whether it's worse if they didn't
know or if they didn't know but
certainly at that time we made
tremendous Mis judgments based on our
fail
to appreciate what the long-term impact
of this episode had been in the hearts
and souls of many Iranians yes sir utter
surprise in the overthrow of the Shah is
the fact that our intelligence was
essentially flawed in other words we did
not believe in the use of people who
were trained in anthropology and other
Sciences in that the United States
embassy staff was very skeptical about
what anyone could tell them about what
was going on in that country
in other words up we isolated ourselves
almost completely from what was going on
in them on the popular level I would
just women with your right and and I'd
add that there's an opposite side to
that coin not only did we not fill our
embassy with anthropologists and
sociologists and historians but instead
we filled it with covert operatives
it was another result of the direction
that the US government took after 1953
when we were sending people abroad we
were sending people who were not
expected to maintain contact with the
grassroots but with the elites and
that's certainly as you say one of the
reasons why we met that great disaster
in Iran yes sir as you said we had 25
years of the Shahs support after the 53
cool and then you drew parallels to the
Iraq situation today would you comment
on what will happen in the next 25 years
all I can say is this I shudder to think
that 50 years from now
somebody will be standing in a forum
like this looking back at our Iraq
intervention and seeing even a fraction
of the horrific after-effects that we've
seen from the Iran operation we have
been caught up in what I see in a way as
a clash of fundamentalisms we're facing
a fundamentalist enemy but in a sense
we're fundamentalists ourselves we've
taken the view that God has given us
such a wonderful country and and such
great freedoms that it's our duty to go
to other countries and share this with
them and spread this and transform them
in our image we've still not learn how
to manage dominance we have become
dominant so quickly the British Empire
and the Spanish Empire and the Roman
Empire in the Persian Empire became
dominant over generations and centuries
the populations of those countries and
the political elites had long time to
accustom themselves to the use of power
the United States has come to this
position of dominance so suddenly that
our ability to deal with it to manage it
has not caught up when we entered World
War one there were less than 150,000
Americans under arms in 1939 when world
war ii broke out the united states was
the 19th biggest military power in the
world
we were just weaker than Bulgaria and
one step ahead of Portugal so this
position we find ourselves in now is so
dramatically new and so dramatically
different from anything that living
memory has experienced that I think
we've rushed very fast ahead of our
ability to comprehend how to deal with
this dominance yes sir oh sorry yes
ma'am you were you were asking first
first of all thank you for your comments
regarding historical and political
history of the coup and one other issue
that
would like to bring up is the loss of
Iran for the Iranians as many of us are
here because of this coup because we
have lost our country we cannot go back
and the emotional and personal loss as a
result of this coup and the brain drain
that has happened since and the the fact
that if that coup had not happened where
would everyone be today
it breaks our hearts and I want you to
comment on that from your perspective as
an American one of the things that was
most painful for me in writing this book
was to see how beloved the United States
was in Iran up until 1953 the Iranians
were very resentful of the British and
the Russians and the French and the
other powers that had come only to suck
out their resources but for more than
half a century American doctors and
teachers and development workers had
been coming to Iran working completely
selflessly they had never sought to
convert people from their religion or
exploit the country's resources one
young American teacher was actually
killed fighting alongside the
revolutionaries in the constitutional
revolution of 1906 in Iran he was
idolized as the American Lafayette we
were viewed as the country that would be
the great model and the great supporter
because we seem to be the logical Ally
for a democratic Iran that's what makes
this coup so heartbreaking when I look
at Iran today and look over its history
of the last 50 years of tyranny I think
to myself put aside all the people that
have been murdered and tortured by those
two repressive regimes think about the
millions upon millions of ordinary
people generations of whom were never
able to fulfill themselves who were
never able to live the normal lives to
which every citizen should be entitled
Iran is a country that was really on the
way to developing something very very
important and very positive it could
have been tremendously helpful also for
the United States and for American
ideals but to see how violently that
process was interrupted is both a
political tragedy for the United States
and the West and certainly a very
emotional and a very personal tragedy
for countless millions of Iranians it
occurs to me that another disturbing
parallel between what's happening now
and what's happening then is the role of
the CIA Bob Woodward in his book Bush at
war details the role of the CIA using
tens of millions of dollars brought in
suitcases by the CIA to bribe various
Northern Alliance Chiefs and etc to
orchestrate the war in Afghanistan and
I'm also disturbed at how this unelected
secret government without accountability
for these tens of millions of dollars
are operating without any oversight
apparently this just occurs to me I
don't know if you have a comment about
that I just make one statement about
Afghanistan and since you mentioned it I
like to hold up the Iran coup as one of
the great examples of the unintended
consequences of intervention but
Afghanistan is perhaps an even more
vivid example because we've lived
through the whole cycle we had a short
term goal which was the overthrow of the
pro-soviet regime in Kabul and we were
willing to do anything to reach that
goal including arming large bands of
radical fundamentalists in Afghanistan
training them in terror techniques and
in the use of
very dangerous weapons and including
biological and chemical ones when we
achieved our short-term goal the
overthrow of that regime in Afghanistan
our attitude was well we're finished
here now we're going home
none of the processes that we set in
motion by arming all these
fundamentalists and drug traffickers is
ever going to have any effect on us it's
never gonna come back to bite us
well what happened we what got a very
rude awakening
we did get bitten what happened on
September 11th was not just an airplane
crashing into a building for us it was
the world crashing into our living rooms
it was a lesson to us that the United
States is not isolated from the rest of
the world and the processes that we
helped set in motion can have terrible
effects for us we need to think about
this more seriously before we begin
launching those processes yes sir
speaking of fundamentalism the holy
Alliance of ex-cons and neutrons and
fundamentalists who are running this
country right now I don't say us because
I can't identify myself with them
contrary to appearances themselves are
fundamentalist in their religious sense
not in only an idea like the the self
elected president gets his his cue from
a fundamental is preached every morning
and contrary to appearances they are
beefing up the Shiite fundamentalist
right now why are we talking in Iraq
they're our closest allies they are
bothering women in the street no woman
has security to go besides everything
else today to her job or so on and
they're doing this bloodletting a lot
after so many years so yeah I don't want
to say anything positive because there
is nothing positive to say about the
deposed regime in Iraq but if you were a
fundamentalist in Iraq you most likely
you'd be under six feet of ground there
there was no tolerance for
fundamentalism at all nor was there
tolerance for any form of political
dissent in Iraq today I think Iraq is
becoming a real center of fundamentalism
and that's one of these long-term trends
that I think is going to come back to
haunt us yes sir in the back I I came to
United States few years ago I was one of
the students that contributed to that I
mean to that reform is campaign for
president cottony and I think that the
people in Iran still haven't realized
that I mean it don't have that hatred
about the United States they are defying
a regime that is against United States
so I I don't think that that the
realization of what happened in 1953 and
the feeling about United says is still
there I think that day that regime is
gone then the hatred of the United
States you know shows up and the United
States should be ready for that day
first and second it is really painful
for all of us to think about the 1953
and what the United States do to us but
it is more painful and it's it's very
very hard to be in United States listen
to what administration says about Iran
about the nuclear weapons again and and
the most painful thing is to see general
public of United States still doesn't
understand doesn't get it what is going
on and you know you're talking to people
and they're supporting the
administration and this is the most
painful thing I've ever had in my life I
think that was very eloquently spoken
you're right I think that the anger
towards the United States that is
naturally still strong in in Iran is
tempered by still a residue of
admiration and
respect I think if the United States can
be patient and not and resist the
temptation to try to push things along
in Iran which will only mess up the
whole project democracy will come back
to Iran now you know more about Iran and
I do obviously but when I was there I
asked a lot of people a question that
people have asked me here and that is
this if such a large percentage of
Iranians despise the regime why don't
they rise up and overthrow it
and her irani and after Iranian gave me
the same answer this is what they said
in the late 1970s we all banded together
against the Shah from the Communists
through the Democrats and the Mossadegh
supporters all the way to the most crazy
fundamentalist we all joined together
under the agreement the understanding
nothing can be worse than this let's
overthrow this and whatever comes next
will be better well guess what
something was worse and now Iranians
have really learned a lesson I think
it's a it's a painful lesson but it's a
important one for a sophisticated
political population which is what Iran
has and the lesson is don't start
overthrowing governments with the idea
nothing can be worse they'll always come
up with something worse let's wait until
we have a blueprint we know where we're
going before we start setting processes
in motion maybe they learned a lesson
from watching the terrible effects of
some other regime change operations yeah
over there son you know I was sort of
waiting in the wings and hoping and I'm
sure there are plenty of people who
wouldn't be surprised if he has backers
and
positions of power so that he might find
his way to power do you think that's
completely out of the question and also
wouldn't it be natural for the Iranians
to see as you mentioned about the 79
events you know that uh you know that
here you know the United States might
use that as you know means of imposing
itself again and that well I think you
see me you're right young razor Shah the
he wants to be raised - ah that may have
been a Freudian slip
young razor Pallavi is living in a
suburb of Washington DC this is a
successful businessman that they had a
lot of investment capital I guess when
they came over he has talked about the
possibility of playing a role in the
future of Iran some of the things you've
said he has said sound intriguing he has
sometimes used the example of King Juan
Carlos in Spain as a person who could
facilitate the transition to a
constitutional monarchy whether he is
sincere or not it's something I wouldn't
dare to judge that's something for
Iranians another scenario I've heard is
that in a future more open Iran Reza
pallavi could go back and run for
president which is a largely ceremonial
a figurehead post Iranians are going to
have to decide this question and and I
just close with this the result that we
all want in Iran a return of democracy
is going to come the large majority of
the people want this I wouldn't go so
far as to try to predict when or how
this will happen but but it will happen
the one thing that can prevent it from
happening is if the United States become
so eager for it to happen that we begin
to intervene directly any politician an
infection any party that is embraced or
supported by the United States gets the
kiss of death imagine what it sounds
like
two Iranians when the Americans shake a
finger at them and say you're not
Democratic enough you should have a
democracy over there in Iran
well they roll their eyes and tell us we
had a democracy 50 years ago but you
crushed it so we don't have clean hands
in Iran many Iranians are aware of that
now I think we have a role we can play a
role in helping to shape events there
but it has to be through coalition's it
has to be through a diplomatic pressure
economic pressure one of the great
successes that Iran has had in the last
few years has been building up strong
commercial relations with Europe they're
very reliant on Europe and they're very
responsive to Europe same thing is true
of Russia why won't those countries help
us pressure Iran very simply because we
don't help them on anything they're
interested in and when we ask them for
favors regarding Iran they're telling us
they're not interested in helping why
should they agree to join coalition's
with us when we want coalition's when
they are not listened to when they have
concerns about what the United States
does foreign pressure in trying to make
sure particularly that Iran does not
develop an offensive nuclear weapons
capability is something very appropriate
but it's not something the United States
can ever apply on its own that will only
have the backlash effect of bringing
millions of people behind a regime which
actually they despise and hope Falls
very soon
well I think with that we've probably
come to the end of our time I really
appreciate you all coming out on such a
night thank you all to the libraries and
it's a great evening
Stephen Kinzer was an international
reporter for The New York Times he's now
based in Chicago his book all the Shahs
men is published by Wiley online at
Wiley calm next week in place of history
on book TV will show the Miami